a playground in an idyllic French
holiday Resort is now a sacred site for
a community in shock
was earlier a man came here armed with a
knife and attacked four small children
incapable of Defending themselves one
victim was in a push chair
they were toddlers between 22 months and
three years old Brave members of the
public tried to stop this senseless and
brutal assault brandishing their
backpacks as Shields before the police
seized him
macrame Atia witnessed the arrest he
came back here to pay his respects with
his own children
I wasn't thinking of an attack in a
children's park right here in Anniston
it's impossible I didn't know what was
happening people were running everywhere
I asked myself what it could be and
after we were informed that there had
been an attack on old people and on
children that's the moment we really
freaked out
an athlete running in the park remembers
the chaos and distress
all of a sudden a mother said to me run
run there's someone starving everyone
around the lake you stab children run
run and I was a bit surprised I carried
on I saw the guy basically right in
front of me
the victims who've suffered
life-threatening injuries include a
young British national
31 year old Syrian man is now in police
custody
terrorism is not thought to have been a
motive a community a country is now
asking why this happened why would
anyone do this